la musique là c'était sur france 2 hier
soir les 12e victoire ont récompensé
mais il faut bien le dire ils ont
récompensé les anciens charles aznavour
meilleur artiste de l'année
barbara meilleur artiste également et
puis eddy mitchell pour le meilleur
album de l'année marc lavoine notre
invité d'hier à lui hérité de la
victoire du meilleur clip on revient sur
ces victoires qui ont couronné les
anciens surtout avec stéphane haumant et
beurre numério ce serait alors le
champion des champions
c'est le jeune homme de la soirée c'est
monsieur charles aznavour
à 72 ans charles aznavour reçoit la
victoire du meilleur chanteur de l'année
normal quand on est le plus grand
mais pour lui ce sont des jeunes que ce
genre de cérémonie aurait dû couronnées
sont les jeunes qui ont besoin qu'on
leur apporte
j'ai pas une une reconnaissance parce
que ça ouvre des portes qu'elles portent
ou les books amour aujourd'hui
franchement chanson de l'année
aïcha de khaled écrite par un vieux
routier de la chanson jean jacques
goldman
avec une révélation tout de même
juliette de la chanson française dans la
grande tradition une victoire
récompensant des années de travail en
attendant la rencontre avec le grand
public
la carrière lcl cnc déjà construites
sans ça donc ça va lui donner une touche
peut-être on en reparle dans quelques
mois je vous raconterai la soirée était
retransmise en léger différé pour éviter
un nouveau coup d'éclat en direct des
intermittents du spectacle on risque de
la meinau ministre rapport à chaque fois
qu'il voit quelqu'un surgir sur scène
ils demandent ça peut être un
intermittent mais surprise cette fois
c'est le ministre de la culture qui
s'empare du micro concert monsieur de se
réveiller et il annonce l'ouverture
prochaine de négociations sur
l'indemnisation chômage des artistes il
eut tout de même un perdant lors de
cette soirée à celle visible ni les
quatre fois le chouchou de la variété
française n'a rien gagné
aucun regret
pour le gardon